Performing is my life, you know, it's what I've been doing for the past 12 years.
With the Black Eyed Peas, there's no nervousness.
You know the songs all by heart.
Performing in the Rose Bowl with U2, and it's 100,000 people,...
...that's a big dream.
Thank you so much. We are the Black Eyed Peas.
Our music has touched, you know, Philippines, Chile, Lithuania, Moscow, Slovakia, Korea.
The music we make, it's colorless.
My biggest fear is like losing touch.
So, I put a studio in my house...
...'cause I don't ever wanna not be connected.
My mom bought me a JVC radio for Christmas one year.
I learned how to record...
...and then loop my favorite parts by playing and pausing,...
...rewinding, playing, and pausing; and then I rap over that.
So, my mom made me hungrier to go out and achieve bigger things.
And then, a song happens.
You could write in the dark.
You in your little studio.
You're hearing the same beat ten times over,...
...and you're getting hypnotized by your own stuff,...
...and you don't know if ever people are gonna react towards it.
Before I write a song, I make a beat,...
...I play the beat,...
...figure out who's building to it and write to that one...
...that had the best response.